I think it's worth to have a cost of
unfortunately some gun deaths every
single year so that we can have the
Second Amendment to protect our other
god-given rights that is a prudent deal
it is rational so then how do you reduce
very simple people say oh Charlie how do
you stop school shootings I don't know
how did we stop shootings at baseball
games
because we have armed guards outside of
baseball games that's why we saw in
Uvalde a team of police officers
countless officers and they weren't
willing to enter the room as they should
have because of the weapon they were
saying there's an AR-15 there's an AR-15
that the shooter had so yes let's have
security let's have locked doors
let's also not make the environment one
this terrifying to go to and as other
countries do let's
reasonably regulate firearms